- Look what just came in the
mail, this is the brand new,
Microsoft Surface Studio 2,
and this thing is incredible.
I had the first version,
some of you guys may
have seen that unboxing,
and I have absolutely
loved it, I've gamed,
I've done design work on it,
I've edited videos on it,
this model that we're about to unbox
has the 7th gen Core i7 processor,
one terabyte solid-state
drive and 32GB RAM.
So let's slice and dice this up,
this knife is so sharp,
it's always so shocking!
Are you ready?
It's got a little illustration here
that shows me that I should
probably lay it down,
so I'm not doing properly.
Oh my gosh, this thing is so cool.
Let's get you outta here, buddy,
let's free you from this prison
that they have put you in.
Your styrofoam prison,
that reminds me of a song
♪ They're tryna build a prison ♪
Does this move down, does
this move it down, come on.
Oh my gosh, I'm so weak
(squeals) it's actually
not that heavy but it's so
awkward to try to hold it.
- [Jenna] You're
awkward to try to hold.
- That's what she said!
OK now we got that out,
we'll get to you in a second,
let's see what else we've got in here.
(rattling)
- [Jenna] Well don't shake it.
- Oh sorry, I don't know, I got excited,
it's like Christmas
morning whenever you're
like going underneath the Christmas tree,
what presents did I get?
To try to figure it out.
Oh we've got the power cable,
I would of never guessed.
We've got, oops, ripped it.
Oh look at that nice glossy finish.
Oh, I wanted to smell the paper
and I gave myself a paper cut.
Here's probably the
keyboard and the mouse.
Ooh and a stylus, don't touch my stylus.
Only like five of you get the
joke, don't touch my stylus.
What a great sound, can you hear that?
(plastic crackling)
should I just do a whole ASMR channel?
- [Jenna] No.
- Okay
- [Jenna] I
won't subscribe to that.
- OK, you won't but
someone would I'm sure.
We've got the keyboard.
Oh, wow, it just popped right out.
- [Jenna] It comes with batteries.
- Yeah, right?
Oh that's nice 'cause
it's just like magnetic.
I love Surface products, like Microsoft
really has done such a
great job with these.
Pull to activate, oh!
I can't hold onto
things, I have a problem.
So that's everything that's in the box.
(plastic crackling)
what a great sound.
So in the back here we've
got four USB 3.0 ports,
to an Ethernet port,
we have, ooh we've got
a nice Thunderbolt port, ooh
we've got a nice USB-C port,
ha, and an SD card slot
and a headphone jack, what!
(plastic crackling)
What is that song?
- [Jenna] You gonna plug it in?
I almost stabbed myself.
This, almost got me.
- ♪ they're tryna build a prison ♪
What is that song?
Play Prison Song, it is System Of A Down.
- [Siri] Now playing
Every Rose Has Its Thorn.
- What? No, absolutely not!
Play Prison Song.
- [Siri] Every Rose Has Its
Thorn by Poison now playing.
- No! Play Prison Song
by System Of A Down.
- [Siri] Now playing Prison
Song by System Of A Down.
- ♪ they're tryna build a prison ♪
("Prison Song" by System Of A Down)
♪ Dun dun dun dun dun ♪
♪ They're tryna build a prison ♪
I'm, OK, I mean I love System Of A Down!
Hey Siri stop playing, before
I get a copyright strike.
She doesn't care about my
copyright strike, stop playing.
Let's plug this in.
- [Jenna] I love your decorations.
- I love what you've done with the place.
- [Jenna] I love
what you've done, wait,
wait, the tiny hat (laughs).
- See, (laughs) you guys,
you come for the unboxing
and you stay for the tiny hat.
- [Jenna] What about
the pig that has boots on?
- The pig has boots on
and the dog's collar,
don't even ask questions, it's like...
- [Jenna] I'm not
'cause I did all that but...
- It's fine.
- [Jenna] Okay.
- Ow, the sheath was not on. OK.
- [Jenna] What are we gonna do now?
- We're gonna turn it on.
Ah, what's happening?
I can't see anything,
is something happening?
- [Jenna] That screen.
- It's honestly so incredible.
Hey, oh.
- Hi there, I'm Cortana
and I'm here to help.
- She wants to help me.
- A little sign in here,
a touch of WiFi there
and we'll have your PC ready
for all you plan to do.
- I have the same reactions every time
I go to the setup screen.
- Just select the little microphone icon
towards the bottom of your screen.
- The little microphone!
- If you need an assistive screen reader,
press the windows, control and enter keys
at the same time to turn on narrator.
- OK, well I'm gonna set this up
and then I'll see you guys in a second.
- That's enough intro, let's begin.
- Here it is, Studio
Unboxing, May 2nd, 2017.
Are we doing an unboxing,
or what are we doing?
I just love that this is touchscreen,
like this is so great.
(YouTube video playing)
I made the same joke.
- [Jenna] You should've
worn the same sweater again.
- I was so worried that I was
gonna wear the same thing,
I should've checked, I wonder
if I made any other same jokes
oh I don't think I said that one yet.
Get this stylus poppin'.
Does this come with a Surface dial?
I think we decided the last time,
it does not come with a Surface dial.
So I've been working really
hard on this illustration
and I just am so excited that
today I get to show it to you.
So I have a secret
talent of drawing, cars,
but I don't like to finish them entirely,
I just like, suppose
I should a little bit.
So this is my drawing (laughs)
I don't know what to do,
so I'm just gonna finish this
up, color this in real nice,
like look at that, wow,
this is so incredible.
I'm graffitiing all over this,
oh that's, change the colors.
This is where kind of a
dial would be really cool,
it's because you can use
the dial to just sort
through the colors and different brushes.
So talented, shall I print
this out, you guys want this?
Do you want my art?
How do I make a new document,
this is my document,
oh my gosh, look at
this, this is so, oops.
Oh my gosh I closed the book,
OK let me open up my sketchbook.
So I would like for you guys to...
Subscribe.
- [Jenna] You spelled it wrong.
- Did I really?
- [Jenna] No.
- Oh my gosh, there's no
Spellcheck on writing.
(gentle music)
Alright, well that's that,
I'm looking forward to checking
this out a little bit more,
I do wanna do a Fortnite test, of course,
that's how I usually always
test out everything is,
will it handle Fortnite Okay?
And I'm sure it will
'cause I played Overwatch
on my last Studio, oh also, by the way,
when you flip it around it's an eraser.
I have not written in cursive,
in so long, it feels weird.
- [Jenna] Piz? Piz subscribe?
- Oh it's a plz, like pliz
- [Jenna] Piz!
- Be nice to me.
- [Jenna] (laughs) piz
subscribe, piz be nice to me!
- Well let me know what
you guys think of this,
I'm such a huge fan of
all the Surface stuff,
I really love the Studio line.
If any of you guys have ever used this
or if you have one, I would
love to hear from you,
leave me some comments below
and let me know what you think
and what should I try out next?
- [Jenna] Piz subscribe.
- Plz subscribe. OK bye.
Look I'm so talented. Ow.
(gentle music)